les fromages frais sont typiquement très
doux et moelleux pense on fêta au quark
ou encore à notre fromage en grains
malgré leur ressemblance la ricotta et
locataires de fromage frais ont des
spécificités bien à eux
en débutant par la texture en général le
cottage est fait à partir de lait écrémé
après il ya certaines pour manger qui
mélange le coach avec un peu de crème
c'est beaucoup plus crémeux la ricotta
c'est beaucoup plus ferme parce que
c'est beaucoup plus j'ai goûté ces deux
formats et se font partie de la même
famille j'étais des fromages et je ferai
la base mais on est loin du code entre
les deux parallèles philippe cotis là et
sylvain et puccini d'ateliers fromager
connaissent bien les différences entre
les deux puisqu'ils les enseignes
comment on peut les faire à la maison
c'est sûr que le plus simple des deux ça
serait la ricotta un type ricotta c'est
le fromage une maison ou un fromage qui
prend le moins d'en fabriquer la ricotta
originaire d'italie et de sous produit
du lait industriellement il est fait
avec le petit lait ou lactosérum
récupérer de la fabrication d'autres
fromages comme le parmesan ou le romano
10 litres de lactosérum ne produiront
que 200 g de ricotta
c'est rare qu'on est à la maison 10
litres de lactosérum c'est pour ça que
généralement ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
utilise du lait entier pour faire un
fromage de type ricotta tombe bien versé
ça dans le chaudron le lait froid et ont
bien chauffé entre 80 et 85 degrés
celsius donc rendu à cette
température-là qui préfèrent s'est
ajouté un assez différent on va brasser
légèrement quinzaine vingtaine de
secondes on va directement voir que le
lait va commencer à flot clé donc on va
voir la séparation entre le gâteau ces
roms et le cahier qui va devenir le
[Musique]
le cottage lui est d'origine britannique
il est obtenu en faisant cahier le
cottage d'hui 7 fromages serait mais qui
demande une certaine maturation de kate
on parle de maturation parle de ferments
lactiques donc on ajoute des bactéries
qui vont acidifier le lait pour maudire
centre 16h à 18h de maturation d'un
point de vue nutritionnel le fromage
cottage présente plusieurs atouts riche
en protéines
il affiche aussi un faible pourcentage
de matière grasse mais vous qui êtes
peut-être moins avec le package qu'avec
la ricotta comme le font les italiennes
vous pouvez éventuellement faire des
tartinades avec pouvait le sucré vous
pouvez le salé vous pouvez pourquoi pas
le mettre dans les pattes
pourquoi pas vous pouvez leur ajouter à
ce que vous voulez il n'y a pas de souci
elles savent au défi a fait travailler
en reconnaissant que peut-être ça va
nous amener dans des zones inconnues
le chef martin j lo du restaurant
pastaga accepter des cuisines et pour
nous deux versions de gâteau au fromage
une avec de la ricotta et l'autre avec
du fromage cottage déjà regarda on
constate que c'est pas les mêmes
textures pour créer son premier gâteau
il a remplacé la moitié du fromage à la
crème contenus dans sa recette de base
par de la ricotta
puis il a fait de même pour préparer son
gâteau au fromage cottage
c'est déjà très absente
le déjà première différence je trouve
que le fromage cottage avec son taux
d'humidité un peu plus grand fait en
sorte que ça devient un peu liquide
mais c'est pas un échec pour autant ça
ressemble au cheesecake normal peut-être
un petit peu plus liquides fréquents
vols cuir l'effet des mesures va arriver
voir est un espèce de coagulant de tout
ça puis quand on voit le cuir ça comme
un blanc je pensais qu'après 45 minutes
cela est beau là une heure plus tard
celui it is pas bien donc une espèce de
textures caoutchouteuse mais on voit la
différence déjà il ya des traces
d'humidité sont restés puis ça avec des
ricotta au juste fromage à la crème ça
ne fait pas ça voilà une fois refroidie
il est temps de comparer les deux
recettes donc dans ce qu'on voit chez
que ces pauvres hères mais oui c'est ça
parce que c'est rare qu'un chef mais
c'est actuellement pas est ce que ça va
donner leur saison
c'est très premier degré là c'est très
léger un peu à l'image de ses gratte
aulas alors on commence par y
ça c'est une réussite
qu'est ce que ça donne avec le cottage
tout aussi intéressant quand même mais
je trouve c'est la chaleur ou c'est le
flexible comme le flins qui a pris le
dessus
c'est plus léger c'est plus léger c'est
vraiment plus léger donc au final on se
rend compte que les produits sont assez
similaires
même s'ils sont différents au niveau de
la confection là le résultat quand les
cuisines ça c'est assez proches l'un de
l'autre
certaines personnes qui mettent dans la
lasagne du fromage cottage c'est rare
qu'on cuisine le côté effectivement
baissé de ricotta on en fait souvent des
murs qui par exemple ça me donne envie
d'essayer de faire cette recette l'est
aussi pour continuer à comparer les deux
je pense que ça va marcher c'est
vraiment
tutto synthèse j'ai envie de goûter aux
deux mois pour pour terminer la société
alors
[Musique]